bring that dress the entire dress this
is instead of my family I just bought a
train with me yeah tell me about this
dress and the perils of walking down a
red carpet with Will Smith I mean it's
pretty crazy but you know why not yeah
this is Brandon Maxwell customs and we
got sketches you know of this months ago
and it's just been a constant you know
conversation and you know color
silhouette all of that stuff but you
know what I love it it's so much fun
doing all of that and you know you can
get to me it gets the creative why not I
think it is creative you were also part
of the crosswalk karaoke how was that
what was that like
tell me give me details tell me
everything oh my god that was hilarious
I think it was funny because I was like
you know the whole gag is like how
dangerous it's gonna be and then we got
there and I was like oh no this is
actually dangerous like this is truly
dangerous and but it was so much fun
well I can't wait to see so cars were
just coming through like people are
coming through like what like it's not
like it's real traffic you know I don't
know what I thought I thought oh it's
like all staged no it's like real for
reals so you know as soon as they cook
you know is the as it goes green you
have to literally run for your life so
you ran for your life yeah I was like am
i insured for this was something yeah it
was worth it it was it's gonna was worth
it good dance scenes are magnificent
what was it like doing these dance
scenes and how much fun was it doing
this and also bringing a different
flavor to the world right now to the
world yeah we brought the flavor and I
love dancing I can like being dance
rehearsals for hours on end because I'm
a bit of a wannabe dancer so I'd always
like hang around with the dances and try
and be cool never like nanana but no I'm
joking they were lovely but ya know if
that was actually one of my favorite
parts of filming was will one of those
people who because he does a lot of 80's
dances they're old they're tired was he
one of those people I'm kidding rust is
[Music]
you ain't a friend
he knows what's up okay new song in that
you're adding a new song to this Aladdin
which kind of changes the feel of it how
important is that changing the vibe and
adding something new to a classic I
think you know it's always about
honoring what's gone before you know it
was personal to me because I loved this
character so it wasn't about kind of
changing it was just about progressing
you know it's a natural progression it's
been 27 years since the original and
it's just you know it's humanizing her
that's my job and that's what I try to
do and all of those plot changes for me
just make perfect sense you know
[Music]
[Applause]